[Música]
os habéis dado cuenta de cómo se parecen
las palabras aula y jaula
he pasado la mayor parte de mi vida en
ellas en aulas me refiero
me apasiona el aprendizaje y me apasiona
la enseñanza aunque es fuera del aula
donde más he aprendido
al terminar la carrera de publicidad
aquí en málaga la curiosidad me llegó en
velero a inglaterra y de ahí el amor me
llevó a japón
me enamoré instantáneamente del país de
la cultura aprendí el idioma hasta que
otro máster encima en japonés me casé y
tuvimos dos maravillosos hijos
sin experiencia en el trabajo que me
surgió pronto hombre y pronto aprendí lo
mucho que me gustaría durante 10 años
fui maestro de inglés principalmente en
preescolar y en primaria los niños me
enseñaron muchísimo para cuando tuve a
los míos propios había tenido bastantes
ocasiones de experimentar con los niños
de los demás
lo que quedaba claro es que lo muchísimo
que se subestiman las capacidades de los
teques hay un potencial enorme
malgastado empecé a experimentar con mis
hijos inmediatamente y el entorno
natural parecía un buen sitio para
comenzar
la montaña siempre ha sido una gran
maestra nos enseñó a compañerismo
tenacidad y amor por la naturaleza nos
enseñó cómo planificar y cuándo
improvisar la montaña también nos
abriría las puertas a descubrir más del
mundo
viendo el progreso físico mental y
espiritual de mis hijos en la naturaleza
esos eran mis mentores y yo no era quien
para negar esa sabiduría
como ejemplos tempranos de nuestras
aventuras en el monte fuji mi hijito con
tres años tres añitos los subió en
tiempo récord y sin lágrimas
el pico del teide el verano siguiente
con cuatro añitos también lo subió en
tiempo récord y hasta volvimos corriendo
la vuelta
los niños sabemos que todo es posible y
nos dejamos guiar por el corazón lo que
había comenzado como un paseo por el
bosque nos lleva a los montes de una
montaña a otras de cima encima y de
maravilla maravilla hemos recorrido más
de 40 países hasta el día de hoy
pero
hay una raíz oscura en esta historia
también
mientras mi primer hijo de dos meses
yacía inocente frente a la ventana
merecedor de heredar un planeta sano tal
y como lo habían hecho casi todas las
generaciones anteriores al otro lado del
cristal a solamente 200 km se desenlaza
va uno de los eventos más devastadores
de la historia humana
el gran terremoto del este de japón
un evento natural tal y como fue el
tsunami que lo siguió la gran pérdida de
vidas fue una tragedia terrible y quizás
inevitable
sin embargo la catástrofe que causó el
tsunami el derrame
radioactivo de la planta nuclear de
fukushima eso sí fue creado por el
hombre
y vamos a tener que vivir con las
consecuencias para una eternidad
más allá de este evento el hecho de que
ese reactor fuera siquiera necesario era
para satisfacer nuestras necesidades
consumistas
quizás sea un poco duro decirlo así pero
indirectamente yo me sentía culpable me
sentía responsable como comprenderéis
estaba enfadado estaba decepcionado era
difícil no encontrar las contradicciones
en nuestras acciones diarias acciones
que alimentan la máquina y que dañan el
planeta
reflexiones sobre el estado de la
naturaleza el papel de la educación e
informar a la siguiente generación
me replanteé en nuestros hábitos de
social consumista y cuál es nuestra
responsabilidad individual en todo esto
como bien sabéis muchas son las
catástrofes medioambientales en el mundo
y lo triste es que reaccionamos
solamente cuando nos toca de cerca lo
más triste es que la mayoría se
encierran en la negación y hay un
peligro de que esté pasando a nivel
global
me sentí incapaz de seguir contribuyendo
al deterioro de la naturaleza durante
demasiado tiempo había participado en un
esquema que no me convencía del todo
pero no conocía alternativas y vivía
cómodamente
una vez que nacieron mis hijos era
incapaz de transmitirles valores en los
que no creían personalmente no supe qué
hacer excepto minimizar mi impacto
minimizar el consumo es una idea difícil
de vender pero es uno de los valores
principales con los que educo a mis
hijos no es un sacrificio explicárselo a
las familias navidades
reciclar está bien rehusar está bien
pero el rey es rechazar nada supera el
simplemente consumir menos
con un sentido de urgencia como si cada
día fuera el último
quise que mis hijos conocieran a la
madre tierra mientras seguía aún con
vida que sintieran la realidad de su
unión con ella que la amaran y que la
protegiera su generación se va a tener
que encargar de limpiar y arreglar el
desastre que les estamos dejando de
herencia
varios fueron los años de asimilación y
de batallas internas hasta que un buen
día guiado por el corazón y sin ningún
tipo de plan dimos un salto al vacío
abandoné la seguridad de mi trabajo
estable abandoné mi vida social abandoné
un sinfín de bienes materiales de los
cuales ni me acuerdo ni me importan
abandoné un futuro seguro y estable por
lo inesperado
desde que dejamos japón rumbo a nueva
zelanda y más allá la vida nómada con
mis dos pequeños de tres y de cinco años
entonces y por tramos por mil con mi
esposa está siendo un camino de continuo
aprendizaje
quizás estéis pensando que sea rico que
tenga dinero
la verdad que no cogió los pocos ahorros
que tenían e intentar sacarles el máximo
de provecho nuestras expediciones
montañistas nos habían preparado para
vivir con pocos recursos
años atrás viajamos como la mayoría
hoteles restaurantes atracciones
turísticas no solamente salía caro sino
que faltaba la conexión con el sitio
simplemente era otro artículo de consumo
ahora buscaba la conexión convivir con
la gente local compartir historias
aprender el transporte público y los
supermercados nos servirían como los
demás conocimos a otros viajeros y sus
experiencias
cuando era necesario acceder a zonas más
remotas comprábamos un vehículo que
luego revendía mos a veces hasta ganamos
otras aprendimos
con fondos suficientes para gasolina
comida y una tienda de campaña o dos
teníamos autonomía total teníamos tiempo
y espacio para permitir el desarrollo
natural de nuestros hijos sin
distracciones superfluas y comerciales
lo aprendido durante el día se retiene
con mucha más facilidad y profundidad
una vez más menos es más
visitamos a viejos amigos y en ocasiones
hicimos booking donde pone buff donde a
cambio de ayudar con las labores
necesarias uno recibe alimentación y se
puede hospedar existen otras
organizaciones que ofrecen servicios
parecidos
hicimos nuevas amistades aprendimos
sobre jardinería repoblación de bosques
vida en la granja qué cosa más divertida
para los niños verdad
para los jóvenes de entre 18 y 30 años
está la posibilidad de un visado working
holiday que permite trabajar legalmente
mientras de viaje
nuestras estancias en ciudades y
poblados serán cortas principalmente
para visitar lugares de interés hacer
las compras e ir a la biblioteca las
bibliotecas ofrecen una ocasión única
para encontrar publicaciones locales
mapas y libros infantiles que no hay en
otros sitios
además hay wifi
adaptándonos gradualmente a vivir con
menos hemos estado deambulando por media
europa en nuestra muy humilde furgoneta
o visto de otra forma muy lujosa tienda
de campaña
si os dijera con lo poco que se puede
vivir fueron los mejores años de mi vida
dormí bajo las estrellas
seguir la luna a lo largo de su paseo
nocturno despertar con el canto de los
pájaros el olor de los bosques después
de la lluvia el peligro nuestra fiel
compañera aunque nunca mostró su cara
gracias a nuestros amigos y guardianes
viajeros y locales de todas las edades
ricos y pobres familias surferos moteros
camioneros caminantes almas libres
feriantes artistas amantes y agentes de
la ley nuestros amigos y maestros se
encuentran repartidos por el mundo allá
donde haya tierra y personas es nuestro
hogar
museos y palacios son algunas de las
habitaciones de nuestra casa
nuestra ola son las montañas y el mar
ríos y lagunas los desiertos y las
junglas
nuestra ola son las calles de katmandú y
los mercados de estambul los vastos
cielos de mongolia los templos de tíbet
y de la antigüedad griega
sin prejuicios dejamos que el lugar
cuente su propia historia
hemos encontrado el hueco de aprender el
ajedrez el backgammon surakarta manejar
las matemáticas entender la química de
la astronomía geografía historia leer y
escribir en inglés castellano y japonés
e incluso amaestrar los legos y tocar un
poquito el piano
por encima de esto
sentimos el mundo sus olores sabores y
dulces melodías se aprende con todos los
sentidos
educar y aprender van más allá de
esquemas rígidos y predeterminados es un
proceso natural y orgánico comprimimos
información en libros y la difundimos en
un número de espacios habilitados para
ello las llamamos escuelas
traemos otros mundos dinámicos y vivos a
un espacio neutro y con poca
involucración personal
en mi opinión una de las carencias
principales que tienen las escuelas es
la falta de movilidad y acaso aprendemos
en ellas cosas que no podemos adquirir
de otra forma
diría que el problema no se halla en la
capacidad de los educadores sino en el
marco educativo que es limitador y
obsoleto años de escolarización
televisión y normalización su primer
muchas de nuestras cualidades innatas
para encajar en un perfil deseado somos
socializados y moldeados el individuo se
convierte en masa como maestro he visto
este proceso de repetirse demasiadas
veces
qué pasaría si nos planteamos lo
contrario llevar el proceso de
aprendizaje al sitio mismo donde están
ocurriendo los hechos donde se hizo
historia sumergirnos y formar parte de
la dinámica misma incluir nuestra
narrativa
no hace falta irse a la otra punta del
planeta lo podemos hacer en nuestro
propio entorno solo es cuestión de
buscar con otros ojos
todos nacemos iluminados
cada pequeñín es un genio
un potencial salvador del planeta único
e irrepetible sin prejuicios por eso los
niños sabemos que todo es posible
cada individuo nace con una solución
única y en lugar de aprender de ello lo
rechazamos e implantamos nuestras viejas
plantillas cada cultura con la suya
educar no es repetir el pasado es crear
el futuro el fundamento sobre el cual
evolucionamos como humanidad
los niños observamos y sentimos y según
el mundo que nos rodea formamos nuestras
ideas
vamos a darles una perspectiva amplia
por lo general los niños somos capaces
de mucho más de lo que se nos permite
vemos de una oportunidad
propongo lo siguiente
evitar la comodidad
para desarrollar la capacidad de
adaptación y mantener la serenidad de la
mente
no a evitar los riesgos más vale
quemarse el dedo con una vela a
desconocer la fuerza del fuego
entrar en contacto directo con el origen
del conocimiento y ser actor en lugar de
espectador
son los intereses y necesidades
individuales los que marcan el progreso
por esto y por otros motivos hay muchas
familias planteándose métodos
alternativos de educación entre los
cuales el homeschooling es la más
prevalente estos métodos alternativos
están en auge a nivel mundial y en el
caso del homeschooling los alumnos
suelen tener un rendimiento académico
superior a la media escolar
no hay un método específico cada familia
se plantea el proceso según sus
necesidades según sus posibilidades y su
forma de pensar
aunque educar a los hijos a tiempo
completo no es algo que todos podamos
hacer requiere de conocimientos básicos
y de muchísima motivación requiere que
estemos permanentemente aprendiendo para
apoyar el desarrollo de nuestros hijos y
proveerles del contexto adecuado para
ello requiere de paciencia y sobre todo
requiere de amor incondicional
la educación va más allá de aulas y de
escuelas es también nuestra
responsabilidad
la nueva generación es todo lo que
tenemos de su educación su forma de
pensar y su actitud claramente depende
el futuro
es fundamental que los niños crezcan con
una conciencia global y hábitos sanos
hay muchísima gente maravillosa haciendo
cosas increíbles
conectando a personas creando
oportunidades para reconectar con la
naturaleza no aires muchas de estas
historias en los medios pero son
abundantes ya todos ellos estamos muy
agradecidos la verdad es que somos unos
novatos acabamos de emprender este
camino y no sabemos exactamente hacia
dónde vamos errores ha habido y muchos
otros sabrá pero descubrimientos también
nos gustaría estar más involucrados y
participar en proyectos colaborativos
siempre abiertos a seguir aprendiendo y
dispuestos a ayudar
todos tenemos algo que aportar tú y yo
no somos iguales
lo bello es que somos distintos y
tenemos soluciones únicas que ofrecer
pero si pertenecemos a la tierra
pertenecemos a la humanidad y
pertenecemos a las estrellas qué
habilidades van a registrar los niños de
hoy para guiar esta nave mañana
[Aplausos]
como se enrolla en los viejos
escuchad niños dile a tu mamá ya papá no
queremos más plásticos no queremos más
azúcar
queremos un planeta limpio y queremos un
cuerpo sano
somos pájaros sin color gracias
[Aplausos]